en este problema nos preguntan el o los
valores de la integral de 0 a 1 de x a
la 4 x 1
x a la 4 entre 1 + x cuadrada de x muy
bien eso es lo que hay que calcular y
bueno aquí nos dan cuatro opciones que
podrían ser así que bueno de ver esta
expresión no no se ve como que se pueda
resolver de alguna forma directa con
sustitución o por partes o qué sé yo así
que pues no sé se me ocurre que
desarrollamos el numerador luego
dividimos y vemos que es lo que va
pasando ok entonces para ir
desarrollando 1 - x a la 4 lo que
tenemos que utilizar en su desarrollo
binomial verdad utilizando
la expresión de un binomio ha elevado a
la cuarta potencia o bien utilizando los
coeficientes del triángulo de pascal y
en el triángulo de pascal nosotros
empezamos con 1 y 1 verdad empezamos 1 y
1 y después tenemos 1 2 y 1 verdad esto
resulta de sumar estos estos se copian y
luego sumamos estos y nos da 3 sumamos
estos y nos da 3 esto nos da 1 y 1 luego
sumamos estos y nos da 4 sumamos estos
si nos da 6
sumamos estos y nos da 4 verdad y aquí
ya llegamos a los coeficientes que
tenemos que utilizar cuando le vamos a
la cuarta potencia esto es el triángulo
de pascal ya hemos visto en algunos
vídeos por qué es que esto funciona y
funciona bien así que vamos ahora a
aplicarlo a nuestro binomio que tenemos
menos x más 1 a la 4 simplemente cambia
el orden verdad
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
poner cada uno de estos elevados bueno
empezamos con menos x a la 4 y que va
descendiendo después va a menos x al
cubo menos x al cuadrado
y en cambio el 1 va a ir de 0 a 4 es
decir lo que voy diciendo es pongo el
primer coeficiente del triángulo y eso
es 1 bueno eso no lo voy a poner y luego
va a menos x a la 4 x 1 a la 0 verdad
luego sumamos 4 que es el siguiente
coeficiente del triángulo de pascal en
digamos en el cuarto piso y esto es 4 x
menos x al cubo por 1 a la 1 verdad
esencialmente los exponentes de menos x
y de 1 deben sumar siempre 4 luego
sumamos seis veces menos x al cuadrado
por uno al cuadrado bien
al 6 ahora va el 4 por menos x a la 1 x
1 al cubo más uno por menos x a la 0 -
equipan o menos x a la 0 es una verdad
por 1 a la 4 muy bien entonces aquí está
ya el desarrollo de menos x + 1 a la 4 y
dejen en simplificar esto esto
simplemente es menos x a la 4 es x a la
4 x 1 a la 0 es 1 y aquí es menos x al
cubo con este - en realidad sale verdad
el menos x al cubo es menos x al cubo
tenemos 4 x al cubo por 1 a la 1 es 1
aquí tenemos menos x al cuadrado es más
x cuadrada entonces son 6 x cuadrada
y 4 x menos x x 1 es menos 4 x más 1 muy
bien y esto ya es desarrollado lo que
tenemos en este paréntesis ahora si
nosotros multiplicamos por x a la 4
tenemos x a la 4 x menos x + 1 a la 4
esto simplemente será multiplicar esta
expresión amarilla por x a la 4 y eso es
x a la 8 - aquí van menos 4 x a la 7 + 6
x a las 6 menos 4 x a las 5 más x a la 4
bien entonces hasta aquí ya tenemos este
numerador y ahora hay que dividirlo
entre 1 x cuadrada y la forma de hacerlo
se da después con la división larga de
polinomios verdad es decir vamos a poner
acá abajo
x cuadrada + 1 x cuadrada más 1 que va a
dividir a esto que tenemos aquí que es x
a la 8 menos 4 x a las 7 más 6 x a las 6
menos 4 x a las 5 más x a la 4 y vamos a
ver que nos sale muy bien entonces
primer punto por cuanto tengo que
multiplicar x cuadrada para que me dé x
a la 8
pues eso tiene que ser x a la 6 x a la 6
x a la 6 x x cuadrada es x a la 8 luego
x a la 6 x 1 es
y quizá las 6 y restamos restamos y
estos se cancelan nos queda menos 4x a
las 7 y 6 x a las seis menos x a la 6
son 5 x a las 6 estos se quedan igual
porque no les restamos nada
muy bien vamos a bajar un poco más la
pantalla ahora cuántas veces cabe x
cuadrada en menos 4 x a la 7 pues cabe
menos 4 x a las 5 verdad menos 4 x a la
5 x x cuadradas son menos 4 x a la 7 y
luego menos 4 x a la 5 x 1 son menos 4 x
a la 5
ahora volvemos a sumar volvemos a sumar
y qué es lo que nos da estos se cancelan
estos también y nos queda 5 x a la 6 que
no le restamos nada
x a la 4 verdad y ahora otra vez nos
volvemos a preguntar cuántas veces cabe
el x cuadrada en 5 x a las 6 y eso son 5
x a la 45 x a la 4 y volvemos a
multiplicar 5 x a la 4 x x cuadrada son
5 x a la 65 x a la 4 x 1 son
5 x a la 4 y ahora si los restamos estos
se cancelan y nos queda x a la 4 menos 5
x a la 4 son menos 4 x a la 4
muy bien recordemos que estamos restando
y ahora otra vez cuántas veces cabe x
cuadrada en menos 4 x cuarta eso son
menos 4 x cuadrada menos 4 x cuadrada
por x cuadradas son menos 4 x a la
cuarta menos 4 x cuadrada por 1 es menos
4 x al cuadrado bien vamos a bajar
todavía un poco más estos se cancelan y
simplemente nos quedan menos 4 x al
cuadrado ahora cuántas veces cabe menos
4 x perdón cuántas veces cabe x cuadrada
en menos 4 x cuadrada esos son sólo
menos 4
no creo que creo que es que aquí resta
vamos verdad si restamos aquí estamos
estamos restando a este de arriba este
por eso es que se cancelan y si restamos
menos 4x cuadradas llevan más entonces
aquí va un más ahora 4 por equis
cuadradas son 4 x cuadrada y 4 por 1 son
4 muy bien si restamos estamos restando
para ya no equivocarnos esto se cancelan
y nos queda menos 4 así que tenemos un
residuo de menos 4 entonces qué es lo
que tenemos ya hicimos esta división
esto de aquí adentro esencialmente es
este polinomio de aquí más un residuo
que es menos 4 dividido entre x cuadrada
más 1 muy bien entonces sólo para solo
para ir anotando qué es lo que tenemos
tenemos
y quizá las 6
4x a las 5 más
5 x a la 4 menos 4 x cuadrada más 4 y
todo esto es lo bueno falta agregar el
residuo verdad que es menos 4 es este
menos 4 dividido entre lo que teníamos
que es x cuadrada más 1 y esto es lo que
hay que integrar respecto de x y
evaluarlo de 0 a 1 de 0 a 1 esto de aquí
es un ser
muy bien vamos a ver si realmente esto
ya es muy fácil de calcular la anti
derivada quizás lo difícil es 4 entre x
cuadrada más 1 pero para eso hay que
acordarnos de lo siguiente que la
derivada respecto de x del arco tangente
de x no es otra cosa más que uno entre x
cuadrada más 1 con esto podemos utilizar
esto podemos utilizarlo para resolver
este sumando entonces empecemos a
calcular anti derivadas quien es la anti
derivada de x a la 6 bueno esto es x a
la 7 dividir entre 7 que es un séptimo
verdad ahora menos 4 x a la 5 eso es
menos 4 x va a ser a las 6 entonces
dividimos entre 6 y tenemos menos 4
entre 6 que son menos dos tercios ahora
vamos a tener aquí x a las 5 verdad
subimos 1 el exponente y dividimos entre
5 pero aquí tenemos un 5 entonces sólo
nos queda así de esta forma luego 4x
cuadrada lo integramos y nos queda
x al cubo así que dividimos entre 3 y
nos queda menos cuatro tercios verdad y
luego 4 la integral de 4 es 4 x 4 x y
ahora este integral pues esencialmente
es menos 4 la integral de x cuadrada más
1 pues será el arco tangente el arco
tangente de este su primitiva muy bien y
todo esto hay que evaluarlo de 0 a 1 muy
bien entonces esto esto va a ser muy
sencillo para el polinomio ya después
veremos qué pasa con el arco tangente si
evaluamos en uno que nos queda nos queda
un séptimo menos dos tercios más uno
menos cuatro tercios más cuatro y luego
menos cuatro por el arco tangente de de
uno de uno es decir nos estamos
preguntando ahora para qué ángulo la
tangente nos da 1
estamos preguntando para qué ángulo la
tangente nos da 1 y recordemos que la
tangente de un ángulo no es otra cosa
más que el cateto opuesto / el cateto
adyacente y si esto es 1 lo que me está
diciendo es que el cateto opuesto es
igual al cateto adyacente muy bien y eso
nos dice que este lado es igual a este
lado pero además sabemos que este ángulo
y recto es decir desde 90 grados
entonces los triángulos que tienen dos
lados iguales pues resulta que este
ángulo es igual a este otro ángulo y con
este de 90 grados quiere decir que cada
uno de estos mide 45 grados para que
todo tenga sentido verdad quizás me fue
un poco rápido todo esto es
trigonometría y geometría básica otra
vez tengo este ángulo que debe ser igual
a este otro ángulo entonces este es de
90 grados entonces tengo 90 grados más
dos ángulos debe ser 180 eso quiere
decir que los dos ángulos deben ser 90 y
eso quiere decir que cada uno es de 45
grados
ahora bien el detalle es que el problema
está está dado en radiales siempre hay
que responder en radiales pero no es tan
complicado
recordemos que 180 grados son pi así que
de 90 grados serán medios y la mitad de
90 que son 45 pues deberán ser y cuartos
verdad entonces estos de aquí son
cuartos radiales y quads radiales o no
hay necesidad de ponerle el radio no es
verdad así que esto de aquí son pi
cuartos y que se va a cancelar con este
4 que tenemos aquí
ahora bien out a todo esto hay que
restarle lo que vale en cero pero
fíjense que si evaluamos las equis en
cero todo esto nos da cero y sólo hay
que ver el arco tangente de cero es
decir para qué ángulo para qué ángulo
tenemos que la pendiente de cero pero si
la pendiente es cero pues es el recto
verdad es es horizontal esta línea
quiere decir que no haya ángulo verdad
no hay ningún ángulo y por lo tanto el
arco tangente de cero es cero así que
estamos restando
todo esto pero muy bien y ya casi
estamos terminando ya ya casi estamos
terminando simplemente tenemos que ver
cuánto vale esto cuánto vale esto porque
menos cuatro por pi cuartos todo esto es
menos verdad con todo y el siglo muy
bien entonces ya podríamos ir dando la
respuesta pero vamos a hacer de una vez
esta suma entonces fíjense que tenemos
menos dos tercios menos cuatro tercios
estos es este de aquí con este de aquí
son menos seis tercios que son menos
menos seis tercios son menos dos estos
de ahí son menos dos y sumamos uno y
cuatro más uno
4 sí y esto nos van a dar cinco menos
dos son cuatro
si estamos bien cinco menos dos son
cuatro
y creo que sí a ver
no es que ya ha sido muy largo el
problema cinco menos dos son tres y hay
que sumarle también este un séptimo
entonces nos falta sumarle un séptimo y
por supuesto restarle step y entonces
dijimos tengo cuatro y uno son cinco
menos dos son tres y le sumamos un
séptimo y luego restamos pi ahora tres
más un séptimo lo podemos pasar toda
séptimos y aquí son 21 séptimos más un
séptimo menos y esto es lo mismo que 22
séptimos menos pi y vamos a ver que esa
es una de nuestras opciones que teníamos
acá y de hecho es la única no puede
haber más verdad la integral de una
función de 0 a 1 de modo que tenga dos
áreas distintas sólo puede tener una
respuesta así que ahí tienes la única
respuesta al problema y ya hemos
terminado